Film Courage: So I looked at your IMDB and
is your first credit THE PERFECT NANNY with
Bruce Boxleitner and Tracy Nelson?
Christine Conradt, Screenwriter: Yeah…I
think that is the first one?
Film Courage: Okay, great.
Is that the one where you got the job from
the re-write and then the producer wanted
to hire you?
Christine: No.
I got fired off that project?
Film Courage: On no!
Christine: That was with a producer where
I was working as an assistant in development
and then left (he sold the company and I left).
He invited me to come back and do this rewrite,
which I did and I think I did two drafts and
he hired another writer (which was fine).
I mean at the time I was sort of sad about
it.
At the time I was sort of sad about it but
it was a great learning experience because…I
didn’t know what I didn’t know.
And so now looking back to see where I’ve
grown because I’m now the last writer on.
It was good for me to go through that experience.
I was very grateful that he gave me the opportunity
to do that experience because that ended up
being my first credit.
Film Courage: So the one [job] that you were
fired off of (without giving away too much
information) but did you see what it was [that
caused it] or was it something that was out
of your control?
Christine: No, I just wasn’t a good enough
writer to do what they needed me to do.
So I did improve the script and a lot of what
I put in there ended up in the final cut but
I think I just didn’t know structure well
enough to be able to fix some of the issues
that they had that they needed me to fix.
And so I fixed the character stuff and then
I think they hired another writer to fix all
the structural stuff that was wrong with it.
Film Courage: And so at that time did you
see it as structure, like a structural defect
or no?
Christine: No.
I couldn’t recognize that at that time.
Film Courage: Interesting.
So then once you were excellent at structure
you saw “Ahhh!
That’s what it was.”
Christine: Right.
And I think also just over time understanding,
getting to know more what they want when they
tell you we need this or we want this what
that means and how to incorporate that into
a screenplay.
We want to add edge to this, it’s not edgy
enough.
That’s a very obscure idea.
So hearing that when I was that early in my
career I don’t think I understood how to
implement edge and now when someone says that
I say okay now I understand the questions
to ask and they can tell me what they really
want and I understand what they mean by that.
Film Courage: Interesting.
So let’s suppose it’s a housewife that
has everything perfect and nothing is wrong
how can you incorporate some edge for that
[story]?
Because I am picturing that this is the Lifetime
movie that I knew which is still interesting
but what edge would we still add to that character?
Christine: Well a lot of times they might
have a dark secret or something in their past
that they feel ashamed of and they’ve kept
from their husband, so something like that
that is just kind of lurking in the background
that seems to resurface and it doesn’t even
have to be kind of the A story.
It an just be something that complicates the
A story, right?
So let’s say you’re a housewife, you’re
trying to get pregnant, she’s finally gotten
pregnant and she has this ex-boyfriend who
is getting out of prison and who still wants
to be with her.
And so now he is going to come back and complicate
her life.
And that may not be the A story but it’s
still something that now she has to tell her
husband who this person is and that kind of
thing.
Film Courage: Right.
And there is the edge.
Christine: And there’s edge and intrigue
to that.
So it’s adding to, it’s rounding out that
story and making people real.
Because everybody has things that they are
not proud of or whatever and so this is something
that you can add those and we can go even
further in the Lifetime movies or TV movies
(so that kind of stuff).
Film Courage: So is the aim to show sort of
the perfection and then as we said before
backing out to show that it’s not perfect?
Christine: I don’t know if it’s to show
perfect.
I think a lot of what intrigues people are
the pretenses, right?
I think so much of what we try to do on Facebook
is to show everybody in the world this great
life we have.
You don’t take the picture of the crappy
Ramen noodles you made last night because
you were so tired to cook.
You take the photo when you’re at the nice
restaurant, right?
Or this beautiful thing that you made, that
you spent hours on.
We put out a life that we want other people
to see because that’s where we think they
are forming their opinions of us.
The irony is that most people care more about
themselves than they care about anyone else
anyway, so they are not even forming those
opinions.
But that’s what we do.
Are characters are the same way.
Our characters live lives based on what they
think they should be living.
And so that’s why it’s fun when you can
kind of flush these characters out and give
them these things in their past or things
that they’re doing or temptations or whatever
that cause those little things of conflict.
Film Courage: And they always have to have
a great place to live.
I mean, I’ve never seen a woman in a Lifetime
movie live in a bad place.
Christine: They live in beautiful houses.
There is definitely an escapism element to
that as well.